conséquence ping-pong ce soir je reçois
jean pierre mocky pour son dernier film
le deal film avec jean claude dreyfus
jacky berroyer jean françois stévenin et
alison arngrim on en reparlera et renaud
jean pierre mocky bonsoir bonsoir mon
cher bonsoir alors moi je voudrais pas
être à la place de critiques parce que
jean pierre mocky n'a pas la réputation
des tendres avec les critiques
ben non mais si vous voulez les
critiques il faut qu'ils en aient mais
il aime le cinéma mais il aime un
certain cinéma et pas forcément lumière
alors ce soir ce sera pierre vavasseur
qui va passer à la moulinette faire
vavasseur du parisien est la risée alors
voilà ça va pas trouver aussi devant le
cinéma le brady puisque ce film passe au
bras dit alors on voir en bas savoureux
a tout pour devenir culte excellent
dreyfus le parisien vous avez libération
le nouvel obs journal du dimanche qu'ils
sont tous très très élogieux sur lui et
on va voir que non alors parlons un peu
de ce film qu'est ce que c'est que le
deal c'est un marché que que face à la
russe qui est un homme qui a tué sa
maîtresse et alors il cherche un alibi
donc le film c'est la recherche de cet
alibi et si demain vous tuer quelqu'un
et vous aurez beaucoup de mal à trouver
un alibi et vous avez une économie aussi
particulière parce que ce film vous
réalisez vous le produisez vous le
distribuer dans une salle qui était
votre âme et il est même sorti chez
gaumont mais n'y est pas resté longtemps
jean pierre mocky avant d'écouter la
critique on va regarder un extrait de
votre film et non par la bande annonce
parce que comme vous le dites abandonné
s'accrocher cher alors on regarde
ah oui j'ai plus tu m'a plu à bulle
un dock est passé sous les bombes qu'est
ce que tu racontes rien ma puce aller
sur mon entrée à temps il faut que je te
parle
si cette histoire de divorce était vrai
ce serait déjà d'un jour ne me souvenais
plus alors maintenant pape est affamé
qui me dit tu viens de vivre avec moi
oui c'est vrai mais c'est la seule la
forme envoyant un mail ou non appel là
et j'avais mis ko pas prononcé il est
tombé de faire moi même me moquer de moi
le téléphone
non
voilà bien jean pierre mocky m'attend
qu'on a vu un extrait on peut pas faire
ma soeur et sa créteil que vous n'aviez
pas vu son fils alors il m'a dit bonjour
jean pierre j'ai rien contre vous du
tout non jean pierre là vous faites un
peu n'importe quoi voilà je peux vous le
dire
c'est à dire qu'elle vous êtes un
cinéaste culte voilà vous le savez sous
prétexte que maintenant vous amuser à
tournez vous bah voilà les sous prétexte
aussi que beaucoup de grands acteurs de
grandes signatures ont envie de tourner
avec vous simplement pour ça comme si
c'était une cour de récréation on allait
faire alors pour la cour de récréation
dont il parle il faut penser que vos
villes fernandel là michel serrault jean
poiret jacqueline maillan ont été ont eu
leurs meilleurs rôles chez moi donc pour
eux c'est peut-être plus une cour de
récréation puisque quand ils sont morts
et qu'on appelait leur nécrologie mes
films étaient en tête alors je comprends
il ya une chose qu'on peut pas vous en
fait c'est que vous redonner leur chance
si je puis dire où en tout cas vous vous
allez chercher des acteurs que plus
personne ne va chercher le reste est
consternant un jean pierre c'est quoi
voilà alors une huile est consterné mais
moi aussi lui il met des étoiles et y
met des étoiles à des crimes qui sont
dans le vent alors j'ai peur d'être
celui dont il peut dire du mal alors
qu'il diluviennes ont fait eux et le il
le dit gentiment mais j'espère je
voudrais revenir sur les acteurs
espionné qu'on refusait de jouer avec
vous ou le désactiver il y en a deux que
lui et pourrait il pourrait rencontrer
pour c'est gérard lanvin vincent lindon
ah oui mais ils veulent pas tomber alors
justement pour la raison que il semble
que ce que lui et certains autres ne
vont pas et même film
donc ils veulent pas être dans un coup
foireux ils veulent ils veulent avoir
des bonnes critiques classique qui est
vécu comme un coup foireux par certains
acteurs pour les recettes oui je peux
pas faire avec des recettes vous savez
jean bigot enfin les gens orson welles
et des gens comme ça jean pierre
melville nous avons toujours été mis un
peu en dehors des normes parce que je
fais pas camping je suis comme un
peintre qui a dessiné brusquement de
faire des toiles qui lui plaisent plutôt
que de faire des toiles qui se vendent
de l'étoile à la mode
écoutons alors écoutons je suis très
franchement si on le regarde bien au
scalpel si on le découpe une découpe un
petit peu on s'aperçoit qu'on n'y
comprend rien en fait alors là c'est pas
vrai
il est simple comme bonjour le fils le
plus intime cherche un alibi il n'y a
pas plus un bruit quand star tué sa
maîtresse et après sa part absolument
quenouille pour passer votre temps à
essayer de trouver un avis qui va
remplacer un alibi qui va remplacer un
oeil et vous pensez que ça ça fait comme
vous dites une comédie grand public
moi je pense avait pas une commune du
grand public je pense ça fait un film de
patronage ça fait d'autant plus un film
de patronage vous ne dirigez plus vos
acteurs par défaut mais de l'acteur sont
dirigés demandé à dreyfus il a trouvé
que je le dirigeais très bien moi fait
quelque chose
fondamentalement ridicule personne ne
voudrait d'un train d'un travail comme
ça dans un chez un éditeur personne en
erreur parce que j'ai eu deux jeux fait
que baby one more là ça tombe mal pour
lui mais il est très gentil et je trouve
ça gênant je trouve ça gênant pour vous
je trouve ça gênant pour le cinéma la
scène censée être érotique avec le cours
de masturbation pour phare alors là lui
il attaque parce que je dis dans le film
que les bonnes femmes doivent seulement
les tout seul parce qu'on leur ait l'ont
pas d'organe et malheureusement ça
choque tous les mecs qui ne donne pas
d'orgasme à leurs fables donc lui il est
peut-être dans ce cas là vous faites
jouer alison arngrim à
qui a été dans la petite maison dans la
prairie vous lui faites avoir des rires
de folles à tel point qu'en ce même il
sait s'en servir à elle c'est pas moi
qui vais faire des révoltes c'est une
folle donc elle rit comme une folle
meldric très bien le rire c'est terrible
pour un comédien d'être obligé de faire
des choses qui font que peut-être c'est
un mauvais comédien à toyako jean pierre
mocky pourquoi faites-vous ça ah ben
voilà
eh bien pourquoi j'ai zappé pour
l'emmerder et puis j'aime bien quand
même
la dernière question pourquoi vous
faites ça vous prenez du plaisir mais je
prends du plaisir justement parce que
dans l'histoire du cinéma tourisme par
exemple drôle de drame qui est un film
que vous devez connaître en 37 les gens
casser les fauteuils il y avait des gars
comme lui qui disait que c'était de la
merde qu'on comprenait rien et c'est en
fait si vous voulez la conclusion de mon
petit entretien avec goût avec grand
plaisir et ben c'est de dire que au fond
un film qui marche c'est pas un bon film
le pardon comme le parent ne marche pas
eh ben il doit être bon malgré notre
camarade que nous aimons beaucoup
ou est-ce qu'on peut aller voir opel au
bras dit voilà le brady bay le bras
disent ses quartiers dans le broyage
ouais c'est shanghai c'est singapour
cccc tunis et djerba
ce film commence dans la rue déjà voilà
non mais c'est il faut y aller au brésil
mais il faut voir ce film c'est pour le
moment nous nous notre drainons que 80
personnes par jour n'en sait pas
beaucoup mais ça va changer en a autant
je pense ce soir on en a convaincu par
doit aussi parler de mots qui s'affiche
c'est toute ma carrière que évidemment
me vavasseur vavasseur ne connaît pas
tout à fait à travers des acquisitions
les plus grands comédiens avec les
meilleures critiques dans la volt un
truc de voix obtenues aller pour faire
va la soeur ce film qui n'a pas non oui
mais alors là c'est une histoire de bin
ça va pas lui plaît alors donc on
parlait le deal un film de jean pierre
mocky alors je rappelle à ne pas voir
parce que monsieur je suis certain que
si pierre levasseur et elle a inauguré à
les voir opinion jean claude et foot
jean pierre stévenin qui meurt très
rapidement la baignoire
jackie berroyer allison la green de la
petite maison d'après et renault dans un
trou d'eau alors mon nom alors je
préfère avoir comme ami renaud laurent
gerra yann moix et vous de l'avoir lui
allez disons 10 ans que pierre brasseur
nous creux parmi ses amis quand même
[Musique]